it costs big money to run a political
campaign
millions were spent on trying to
convince us to vote leave donated by all
these people some giving small sums a
few giving huge amounts this is the
money that helped persuade the country
to ditch the European Union two and a
half years on Sky News has been to see
three of the biggest backers the trio
who provided millions of pounds to
support the brexit campaign and what we
heard from all of them was anger
Peter Hargreaves is the billionaire who
gave the single biggest personal
donation during the brexit campaign 3.2
million pounds now he thinks bricks it
will be blocked
I don't think brexit will happen it'll
it'll go on and all along will this and
in the end I don't think brexit will
happen I think will we will remain in
the EU as we were before
and it will all have been misspent
energy do you regret the money that you
gave to the leave campaign well it does
seem to me that it was what I was
wasting my money I I couldn't have
believed that if we won I we we got the
vote to leave that that people would
just ignore the fact that the electorate
had said we would like to leave Thank
You Jeremy Hosking donated more than one
and a half million pounds vote leave
described him as a true patriot but now
like Hargreaves he says he'd rather the
UK remains in the EU than except Teresa
Mays withdrawal agreement right now
remaining looks better than the
mrs. Mayes deal because when mrs. may
deal we will have lost article 50 will
be in a customized straitjacket with the
EU whereas if we were to remain we can
look at the whole thing from a for a
fresh standpoint
Stuart wheeler funded the leave campaign
with more than six hundred thousand
pounds he told me brexit had been
squandered bitterly disappointing mrs.
may throughout that period has behaved
as if we were the supplicant as if we
had to go begging the EU to be nice to
us talk to most people in British big
business and you do hear the same things
demands for clarity a fear of a No Deal
breaks it but these men are different
they spent millions bucking the winning
side in the referendum and they think
they understand brexit more than most
and when they look at the political
process they feel just made perhaps be
trained and they're in the mood to fight
back Peter Hargreaves says he'd now be
willing to bankroll a new political
party one that would exist simply to
push through brexit
I honestly think there would be enough
people who would vote purely for
candidates whose main criteria was to
get brexit done I'd get me checked out
for that you would yes this is an
important intervention Hargreaves is
keen and well resourced he's wealthier
than Donald Trump and he's got support
we need to get the band back together or
indeed form a new band yes two and a
half years after the referendum campaign
they helped to pay for all three of
these men V ment Lee opposed to resumes
deal with Europe brexit and what it
means seems more divisive than ever
Adam Parsons Sky News